fachleute der nasa und des deutschen
zentrums für luft- und raumfahrt dlr
staaten einen neuen versuch den maulwurf
der mars sonde inside wieder in gang zu
bekommen kurz nach dem start war der
bohrer stecken geblieben ist das
wirklich die letzte möglichkeit ihn zu
retten klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen hier bei
pixum science fiction halten wir euch
regelmäßig über die neuesten
entwicklungen bezüglich der nasa mission
mars insight auf dem laufenden und das
ist wirklich spannender als jeder fehler
ende februar dieses jahres 2009 10 ging
der bohrer der mars sonde insight an den
start doch schon nach rund vier stunden
musste er kapitulieren 4000
hammerschläge waren es bis dahin doch
plötzlich ging gar nichts mehr und der
maulwurf kippte seitlich um 15 grad und
seitdem tritt die nasa mit dem
experiment hp 3 mit flo in physik
properties package quasi auf der stelle
die fachleute sind frustriert hatten sie
noch große hoffnung in dieses experiment
gesteckt allen voran natürlich die
fachleute der nasa und des deutschen
zentrums für luft und raumfahrt denn ihr
plan ist gigantisch die raumsonde sollte
sich bis zu fünf metern tiefe in den
mars boden graben um dann den wärmefluss
aus dem inneren des roten planeten
detailliert zu erkunden
ermöglicht wird das durch die
kombination aus bohrhammer und eines
temperatur senders durch den neben der
wärmeverteilung auch die beschaffenheit
das maß inneren damit erstmalig
analysiert werden kann oder besser
gesagt könnte denn der bauhof sitzt fest
und alle bisherigen versuche ihn aus
seiner misslichen lage zu befreien sind
gescheitert jetzt ist ein neuer anlauf
geplant den maulwurf doch wieder ans
graben zu bringen damit er letztendlich
dann doch die geplanten tiefe erreicht
lange zeit hatten die expertinnen
experten analysiert warum genau der
maulwurf fest steht seit juni 2009 10
ist die ursache des problems aber klar
denn der roboter haben hat er das
gehäuse des bohrers angehoben und dann
gesehen dass der raumsonde wohl es an
seitlicher reibung fehlte dazu der
dlr-forscher tilman spohn bei einer
tiefe von 35 zentimetern hatte der
maulwurf die führungs federn das kochen
es verlassen und sich dann aufgrund
unzureichender boden reibung im kreis
gedreht ohne weiter vorzudringen
es zeigte sich dass offenbar eine feste
größe von etwa zehn zentimetern
zementierten salz über recht lockeren
sand liegt im sommer versuchten die
expertin experten deswegen also das loch
um den mars mal drauf einzudrücken
doch diese versuche mit der flachen
schaufel und deren spitzen seite
misslangen die forschenden mussten
enttäuscht feststellen dass die kruste
wohl zu hart und widerstandsfähig ist
bei dem neuen anlauf der in einigen
wochen starten soll muss also anders
vorgegangen werden geplant ist es mit
hilfe der schaufel des roboter am druck
von der seite auf den mars maulwurf
auszügen und zwar während dessen dieser
anfängt wieder zu bohren
die fachleute erhoffen sich dass dieser
gegendruck ausreicht um den bohrer
tiefer in den untergrund eindringen zu
lassen damit könnte die reibung wieder
erhöht werden
diese taktik wird auch als training
bezeichnet das problem dieser plan kann
nicht vorab auf der erde ausprobiert
werden da der boden des mars nicht
einfach so repliziert werden kann dazu
themen spuren wir wissen nur so viel
über den boden wie uns die bilder zeigen
zunächst muss der massmart wieder zum
leben erweckt werden sprich erneut
aktiviert werden damit der roboter am
überhaupt den druck von der seite
ausüben kann müssen die fachleute der
nasa in die trickkiste greifen denn
seine eingebauten sicherheitsparameter
lassen diese aktion eigentlich gar nicht
zu dazu der nasa ingenieur architekt
bioland wir werden den arm anweisen über
seine vorgesehenen parameter hinaus zu
agieren er kann aber nicht so auf den
mars maulwurf drücken wie es ein mensch
könnte es wäre einfacher wenn er es
könnte aber das ist einfach nicht der
abend den wir haben
falls auch dieser plan nicht aufgehen
sollte werden die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler den maasburg aber
nicht ohne weiteres aufgeben
möglicherweise ließe er sich nämlich
auch retten indem der krater aufgefüllt
würde dazu könnten die roboter am
schaufel oberflächenmaterial in das loch
kratzen ja wie sah der mars eigentlich
früher aus anklicken anschauen und hast
du comics tv abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran